the Joe Rogan experience what do you
think would be best case scenario for
Native Americans in United States like
I'll sort of give you the magic wand
again like what would be best case
scenario because the strange thing that
we have in front of us here is that
there is one country the United States
but there's not just the United States
North American citizens here there's
also Native Americans of various
different tribes right that have their
own reservations and as you said they're
sovereign and they can kind of make
their own decisions what would be what's
the magic wand how do you clear up all
these problems associated with the mean
that the horrific treatment the
everything from alcoholism to the
problems with schools to self-esteem
issues all these problems in North
America while also not the the Native
Americans in the way I'm looking at it
they want to stay a member of their
tribe and they don't necessarily want to
be just Americans they want to keep
their heritage right universally mm-hmm
how does that how do those two things
work together how do you how do we all
live together in America and yet have
these tribes and do it in a way that
works best for everybody right well
that's a that's a complicated ask
question you just freaking have even
with a magic wand I'm not quite but it's
a process and part of it is is these
myths that we have to correct and that
we have to we have to find a new way to
be able to tell our stories and not rely
on non-indian authors to tell our
stories but you need to hear our stories
from us we need to be able to tell our
stories and to reteach the
general public about who Native
Americans are where we've been and where
we want to go where don't we we we've
had this kind of pretend fantasy world
about about Indians uh you know
Pocahontas
Columbus stories Custer
they've all been stories that have fed
into the American politic in a certain
way at certain periods of time and what
I want is that this is the time now
where tribal nations have a lot to lose
and we're in a current administration
that is trying to terminate us once
again what are they doing differently
than other administrations well they
they just they are taking land out of
trust status they would there are groups
that are attacking the basis of federal
Indian law and the rights that we do
have so there's there's an act called
the Indian Child Welfare Act was passed
in 1978 and it's an act that the
Association was heavily involved in to
get passed and it started with some work
with the Spirit Lake Sioux tribe and a
woman came to the people back then and
said they took my kids they stole my
children and after investigation it was
found that it wasn't just happening at
Spirit Lake but it was happening all
over Indian country were state welfare
workers were taking Indian children in a
disproportionate rate a quarter of all
Indian children during that period of
time were taken away from their own
families and adopted out to white white
families and so the Indian Child Welfare
Act required state courts to do things
before a child was taken away
from its tribal nation there are groups
now that are working to dismantle that
act and that's being support because
they they think it's racist so they so
it's it's like they've taken it and and
are looking through the backwards mirror
yes so instead of it being an act that
was passed to protect our children and
to make sure that that children had ties
to their culture and their families
they're saying that that's not in the
best interest of children so they're
still looking at Indian tribes as we
can't take care of our own kids that our
way of life is is not acceptable and
other adoptive families would be better
and what's interesting is that the
Indian Child Welfare Act doesn't prevent
non-indian families from adopting
children it just requires a certain
process to make sure that the the
affiliated Tribal Nation is involved in
that placement and adoption process and
and so that the child can maintain those
those connections or that they tried to
find a family that's more culturally
appropriate for the child so there's
just been actually came out of the
Goldwater Institute which is a Goldwater
when he was a what was he a senator he
actually voted for the Indian Child
Welfare Act but today the Goldwater
Institute is is actually funding cases
around the nation to attack the Indian
Child Welfare Act what is the what is
the reason behind it I mean what are
they trying to achieve they say it's not
in the best interest of Indian children
and even though there are child welfare
organizations around the country that
say the Indian Child Welfare Act is
actually the gold standard in child
welfare and that we should be utilizing
those principles that are used in the
Indian Child Welfare Act to protect all
all children to maintain familial
connections
[Applause]